goats in a bad way i'll give you the
first pick because you're the first one
you got you're gonna give me the
the first pick i'll give you the first
pick man um okay i don't know why are
you ready for this
i wasn't ready y'all i was expecting to
answer a question and then kind of get
my thoughts ready but it's okay i could
do this either way i'm not worried about
it i think i'm gonna go
goats in a bad way my first one uh
i'm gonna go andy reed andy reed that's
gonna be my first one
andy reid eric b enemy for the offensive
game plan in general
i am that's going to be my first one i
am shocked still like i said to start
the show
that they came out with a bad offensive
line against that d-line
and really had limited ways to throw the
ball short and get the ball out of hand
out of mahomes hands it's like they
expected
to see the same defense they saw in week
12. they thought they're going to see
the same attack and it was not and there
was just
never an adjustment and really uh you
know just a lack of a game plan to
attack the way the bucks attacked them
yeah i i agree with you and that was on
my list i mean for me the most obvious
one that stands out that helped
get the chiefs off the rails early was
tommy townsend
you can't you can't show up at the super
bowl
and and perform like a high school
punter
with 27 and 29 yards you can't do it you
can't do it
it's the super bowl and and there is an
argument to be made that well
here's what happens when you have a
punter that you never use and all of a
sudden you got to rely on him in the
biggest game in the world
and uh you know he's going to freak out
a little bit well he did
and i it's a shame that it happened but
hey you got one job kick the football as
far as you can
with some direction from time to time
and to have a couple of shanks like that
and then he had that one drop he dropped
the ball and
oh my god he wasn't crisis rushed that
one but it ended up being a penalty and
then he got the ball back and
he hit another crappy one right yep so
not good not good i don't know that it's
enough to get him fired but but it
definitely wasn't
it's good it's bad enough to get him uh
goats in a bad way
all right round two all right round two
man they're just the you know the the
offensive defensive line all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna do this
i'm going to go to hill and kelsey i'm
throwing them both on there
and again i know it was a tough day for
them and i don't want to blame them
she had 133 yards i know but it wasn't
enough in the competitive part of the
football game i
it was it was you know and again like i
said
the game plan didn't set it up so it set
it up to where they were open a ton
but i'm i'm just going goats in a bad
way because of the two plays
the two plays that were big plays and
they're superstars
and you're playing a team that was
playing better than you at that moment
on sunday you needed to make some plays
to help your football team
and tyree kill with the drop touchdown
pass
which was just an out of this world
throw
i mean just a one-arm rubber band flick
30 yards weird body position
and it went through tyreek hill's hands
and hit him in the face and then the
third down by travis kelsey
when you felt like hey the bucks had the
momentum but the chiefs are still
hanging around
and you just thought like you said
earlier it just
maybe they can get it go we're just
waiting for that one or two plays to
jump start them
and maybe that could have been it but
those were two big moments where
could have swayed the game by two of
their best players and they didn't come
through in the clutch
i'm going to go with prashad breeland
and i'm old enough to remember as i
tweeted the other night when bashar
breilin was the guy who was getting
torched by antonio brown
week one monday night football
pittsburgh washington right when we all
were wondering why the hell isn't josh
norman traveling with antonio brown
they kept putting brown on breeland and
breeland got torched all night breeland
got better as a player since then but uh
hey he was the weak link in that
secondary
on sunday night and and even though the
penalty was questionable it was that
pass interference call on him
when mike evans went down and the
buccaneers got themselves in position
for
the touchdown that made it 21-6 no doubt
and the defensive holding was on him on
the tipped interception too they called
that on him you know which i i really
don't agree with that call but
yeah uh tough day and again that to me
is something we didn't really hit on
there must have been
some real conversations with the bucks
coaches
uh with the referees about kansas city
holding and doing those things like that
you know there must and which hey listen
the game against the bills in the afc
championship game
they let them play that game and maybe
that's what they saw and didn't like
i mean i i i there's a part of me that
wants to go with the refs but we've
talked about it enough and i'm not
going to deal with it in either way and
i don't want to take away from tampa
being the better team
i'm going to go with the chiefs d-line
i'm going to go with the chiefs d-line
because to me that was
you know one thing we didn't get to hit
on and the great reason of why the bucks
offense had so much success
is the fact that they ran the ball so
successfully
and never gotten to third and long a
whole lot to wear or
second and long to where spags and that
chief's defense could do
all their crazy stuff and blitzes and
disguises all that
they never were able to do that and then
because of the run game
it simplified kansas city and they had
to start playing defenses to stop the
run and they started getting gashed
and that to me i mean that bucks o line
big physical everything like that but
we've seen that chiefs d line
stop derek henry the 49ers the browns
all these teams
and they couldn't stop these big suckers
in tampa and that that that was a big
issue in the game
and i got to go chief zolon i mean we
got one game to draw these goats from
and in the offensive line we saw it well
established and
you know maybe it wasn't as bad as it
looked and patrick mahomes tried to
throw him a little bone yesterday but
it was proud fisher without mitchell
schwartz you've got mike rummers and
andrew wiley at tackle and
uh it it it opened the floodgates early
and often but
you know it all ties together with what
you're saying earlier with andy reid
they didn't do enough to help those guys
uh it just it was stunning to see
a chiefs team that we have become so
accustomed to being dominant
get dominated and have no answers and
have a game
of all the worst possible times you
could have just one of those
stuff happens although other than stuff
happens type of a game that's not the
one you want to have that moment in
that's what's amazing to me that it
happened
then yeah the biggest stage in the sport
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports